gamora from guardians of the galaxy
knows better than anyone else the
parents just don't understand
especially when their power-hungry
madman like Thanos who aren't your real
dad anyway
we hope to remember you after 10 years
in 18 movies Marvel Studios finally
pulled the trigger on having the mad
Titan Thanos go toe-to-toe with the
Avengers but while everyone knows the
Eternals main mission is to acquire all
six stones for the Infinity Gauntlet a
big part of that mission revolves around
his adopted daughter Gamora
but how did this relationship again in
the first place it changes depending on
whether you're talking about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or the comic books
and also depending on which comic you're
reading but the general skeleton of
their relationship remains the same no
matter what
forget the finer details this is all the
stuff you need to know about the
relationship between Thanos and Gamora
has established in the comics Gamora is
the last surviving member of a pacifist
race called zen who beerus or zinho
buried as they say it in the MCU when
she was a young girl her people were
completely wiped out by a powerful
invading force afterwards
Thanos discovered her alive and decided
to adopt her seeing great potential in
her as a deadly warrior on the surface
that's pretty selfish but in an
accidental fashion it's also sort of
nice that act of compassion for the sake
of violence in the midst of utter
destruction would do a lot to warp the
Morris developing mind in the comic
Canon but in the movies it's so much
worse in gamora's comic origins it was
the evil mages and his grand inquisitors
who had destroyed her race but in the
movies it's established that Thanos
himself is the one who exterminated her
folks giving their relationship an
intense and complex twist with an icky
undercurrent of emotional abuse over the
course of her childhood and adolescence
dados was a stern disciplinarian of a
father who only occasionally betrayed
his compassion for his war and the harsh
upbringing hardened Gamora into exactly
the sort of warrior Thanos wanted her to
be but in spite of his goals of galactic
domination and mass murder he's not 100%
evil regardless of everything else
Bannos does love his adopted daughter in
his own weird way while he's violent and
harsh to Gamora he's flat-out murderess
to anyone who hurts her the ninth issue
of warlock and the Infinity watch sees
Gamora
attacked by a group of violent crooks
who outnumber and outmatch her while she
was saved by thanos it was only after
the gang had already brutally beat her
her body broken Bannos demonstrated his
peculiar compassion by nursing her back
to health making her better stronger and
faster than she was before replacing her
entire skeleton and enhancing her
reflexes respiratory system and physical
strength he also removed her tear ducts
so that the young woman would be
unspeakably hard life would never know
sorrow again which may not be how that
works on any level but it says a lot
about Thanos his mindset Gamora stayed a
ward of Thanos into adulthood sticking
by her guardian side until she
discovered banishes genocide Alam bish
ins which he intends to realize with the
full power of the Infinity Gauntlet that
realization was all the inspiration she
needed to turn against the Titan once
she realized that her adopted father's
obsession with death on a massive scale
was the real deal she set out on her own
finally able to develop her own moral
compass separate from Thanos the worst
dad ever no spoilers here but a major
aspect of Avengers infinity war revolves
around Thanos's genuine love for
gomorrah giving the death-obsessed titan
a disarming amount of emotional
complexity but that compassion is
outweighed by almost everything else
Stannis does leaving Gamora with no
choice but to stand against the man who
raised her and made her who she is
that should catch you up on just about
everything you need to know about Thanos
and gomorrah's relationship see where it
all leads in the certified fresh'
Avengers infinity war thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]